ولكن كان من المفترض أن نذهب إلى ديزني في غضون
أسبوعين،
لذلك كان ذلك صعبًا للغاية فبدلاً من
التخطيط لقضاء إجازة صيفية عائلية،
اضطرت عائلة Splendid إلى التخطيط
لجنازة أديسون رود البالغة من العمر ثماني سنوات والتي
ذهبت إليها لإجراء عملية جراحية في
مستشفى شرق تينيسي للأطفال  تمت
إزالة لوزتيها يوم الثلاثاء الماضي وفي أقل
من 24 ساعة
نزفت بشكل أساسي في أقل من دقيقتين
وكان يقوم بإجراء الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي في
الحمام حتى وصول المساعدة،
ويقول والداها إن الشريان الرئيسي انفجر وكانت
تشعر بالرعب، كما تعلم كلما خرجت
من الغرفة  لقد قالت للتو لأبي إنها
أعلنت موتها دماغياً، وأنه بعد
يوم الاثنين وفقاً لمجلة
الجمعية الطبية الأمريكية،
نادراً ما يموت الأطفال بعد هذا النوع من الجراحة،
ولكن حدث في العام الماضي أنهم وجدوا أن
سبعة من كل 100000 حالة وفاة كانت مرتبطة
باستئصال اللوزتين في الغالب بسبب بعض الأسباب
السابقة.  - وجود حالات مزمنة ولكن
يقال إن آدي كان يتمتع بصحة جيدة.
السؤال الكبير لماذا حدث هذا ما
نحاول اكتشافه نعم هذا
ما نحاول اكتشافه أعني
أنه
يبدو وكأنه حادث غريب
لكننا نأمل أن  سوف يلقي تشريح الجثة
مزيدًا من الضوء على ما
حدث بالفعل بغض النظر عما حدث. إذا كان يجب
وضع الطفل تحت التخدير،
فلا ينبغي أن يعود إلى المنزل في
اليوم التالي أو في نفس اليوم، بل يجب
مراقبته لمدة تصل إلى 24 ساعة.
نحن نؤمن بذلك، وهذا ما ندفعه
للتوعية بأن تواجدنا عند أصواته
لم يكن الصيف الذي خططوا له، ولكن
معرفة أن أعضائها ستساعد في إنقاذ
طفل آخر هو القليل من الراحة في
حملهم خلال ذلك، إنها بطلة، إنها بطلتي،
هي بطلتنا  في نوكسفيل جويندولين
دوبري أخبار WVLT